The marthon
one of the greatest feats of strength
and endurance in the world.
Some runners prepare for months,
maybe even years.
But for today's challenge,
we're going to complete
a marathon without
any training.
Well, on today's episode,
we're going to find out.
It's common knowledge that a marathon
is 42 km (26.2 miles) long.
But have you ever heard of an
These are races where
people run anywhere
between 50 to 5,000 km.
Some races take place over several days.
Nearly 50% of the competition
fail to complete.
But the rest do end up
crossing the finish line.
So if these people
can run hundreds of kilometers,
surely you can run a measly 42 km.
Right?
Okay,
let's get off the couch and do this thing,
and see what's happening inside
your body as you run.
Your body shouldn't have a hard time
handling this at the start.
Even without training
you should be able to
complete this distance
within 10 minutes.
And as you continue, your lungs
will start to expand more rapidly.
You'll also feel the need to
breathe with just your mouth,
rather than your nose.
This allows your body
to pull in more oxygen,
and at a much quicker pace.
So by now, you've been running
for at least half an hour.
If you're not used to physical activity,
this would probably be the point
where you'd end your attempt.
But that's not really our
style on Your Body On.
We finish our challenges,
no matter how hard they might be.
So get moving!
As you continue running your marathon,
you'll notice your body
feeling much hotter.
Let's take a closer look.
At the beginning of the race,
your core body temperature was around
37 °C (98.6 °F).
Now, if you're not used to running,
your temperature will rise
to 39.4 °C (103 °F).
This might not sound that bad,
but it's the equivalent of a high fever.
And the higher your core temperature is,
the more difficult it is for your heart
to pump blood out
to your muscles.
Let's keep going to find out.
You're now about
You're incredibly exhausted.
But the good news?
Your body is burning an
insane amount of calories.
At the start of your run,
your body was burning about
150 calories every hour.
But now, your body is burning nearly
800 calories per hour.
That means you could eat a Big Mac
and a small order of fries,
and within an hour,
burn the entire meal off.
OK,
now your run is becoming more difficult
than ever before.
You've hit what's known as
This happens after your body has burned
its entire supply of glucose.
Glucose is stored in your
muscles and liver,
and is your primary source of energy
during your run.
Normally, experienced runners
will start their marathon
off slow to avoid this part of the race.
But you came bursting out of the gate,
and now your glucose is expended.
And it's harder than ever to keep running.
Your muscles now need more
to help operate,
and as a result,
you're feeling more sluggish than ever.
By this point,
you're at least 6 hours
into this terrible idea.
An experienced runner would be
finishing the race with
But for you,
the muscle tears would be even worse.
You'll also have an increased
amount of lactate
in your leg muscles,
which will lead to cramps.
At this point,
you'll be lucky if you can
crawl to the finish line.
But your leg pain wouldn't even
be the worst part of all this.
Your kidneys would suffer even more.
A 2015 study
found that 82% of runners
had stage 1 acute kidney injury
immediately following a marathon.
These injuries happen when your
kidneys aren't getting enough blood flow.
They're also due to dehydration.
During this time your
kidneys aren't able to filter
toxins out of your blood.
So yes, in theory,
you could finish this marathon
without any training.
But you'd probably end up
bruised and beaten,
and possibly, in a hospital bed.
Yeah, this is a challenge
you don't want to try.
If you want to run a marathon safely,
here's some advice:
Coaches say that you should run
a total of at least
And you should be able to
do this comfortably
if you want a real shot at this race.
Remember to stretch as much as you can,
to stay hydrated,
and to walk when you're feeling weak.
This will help you finish the race
without any serious injuries.
Follow this advice so you
can kill this challenge
instead of having it kill you.
So that's your deep-dive
into running a marathon without training,
and it's tough to recommend.
What about another test of your body?
Like eating McDonald's for a year straight?
We'll see what that challenge brings
on the next episode of